y es parte de nuestro compromiso Rafael
hablar de la importancia de los latinos
allí lo que representan eh Eh
políticamente bueno marco Rubio es un
descendiente de eh migrantes
latinoamericanos Qué significan los
latinos para la política de Estados
Unidos bueno en efecto la primera
observación que yo haría es que no se
puede asumir que el latino siempre va a
votar demócrata sino que Dependiendo el
estado y dependiendo las condiciones
particulares puede sentirse más o menos
afectadas por las decisiones que se
tomen a nivel federal y a nivel Estatal
esa sería una gran observación hay que
tener en cuenta una cosa La minoría
latina es de las que más ingresa
anualmente nuevos votantes pero vemos
Que si bien ese grupo de 18 a 35 años
favorece tradicionalmente a los
demócratas No necesariamente salen a
votar en el año 2008 y en el año 2010
las elecciones de Barack Obama
produjeron importantes victorias de los
latinos que votaban demócrata en Texas
en Florida y en algunos otros estados
pero esa emoción y esa Esperanza que se
obtuvo en ese momento se fue diluyendo
como lo mencionó Lawrence anteriormente
cuando Donald Trump llegó a decir acá
vamos a cerrar básicamente las fronteras
y ahí volvió un tema importante de
confrontación en algunos estados como el
estado de Nevada el estado de Arizona el
estado de la Florida eventualmente en
las carolinas pueden ser importantes han
venido creciendo en algunos distritos
especialmente la comunidad mexicana en
el estado de Illinois donde tiene una
importante afluencia va a ser importante
y seguirá siendo decisivo además
obviamente de el estado de Nueva York
además obviamente del estado de
California por supuesto pero digamos que
es un voto que muta es un voto que
trasciende y que sin duda alguna se
comporta De manera pendular de acuerdo a
las características importantes por
ejemplo en Nevada una gran cantidad de
mujeres latinas y devoto se sentía
relativamente defraudado con las
políticas que se tomaron a nivel Estatal
al mantener durante más tiempo cerrados
los centros de entretenimiento como Las
Vegas Entonces eso afecta mucho la forma
en como responde en particularmente a
estas elecciones de medio término
actualmente ponen más de al menos 34,5
35 millones de votos en los distintos
estados de la unión Y eso es importante
seguirá consolidándose eventualmente
como la segunda minoría más importante
después de la afroamericana y en efecto
va a seguir siendo decisiva en algunos
estados hemos visto que en la Florida
seguirán favoreciendo un voto
particularmente conservador muy cercano
a los republicanos pero en otros estados
variarán y modificarán su voto de
acuerdo a como particularmente se
identifiquen sus intereses de karate más
como migración empleo Y por supuesto
seguridad social seguridad social que
eso implica entonces
hospitales digámoslo así la el acceso a
la salud y también el acceso a educación
en cierta forma también puede tomarse
por ahí que es una de las deudas
pendientes que tiene el sistema estado